الحصول على زيت الزيتون سيصبح صعبا جدا في
ايطاليا والسبب بكتيريا نشرتها حشره طائره
قضت على 21 مليون شجره زيتون مثمره من اصل
60 مليونا في ايطاليا التي تحل ثانيا
عالميا في انتاج وتصدير السائل الذهبي بعد
اسبانيا هذه البكتيريا القاتله من نوع
اكزيليا تعمل على منع حركه المياه في
الشجره ما يتسبب بتحول لون الاوراق الى
الاصفر والبني قبل سقوطها ثم تسقط فروعها
بعد ذلك مباشره هذا النوع من البكتيريا
ظهر قبل عشر سنوات تقريبا في منطقه بوليا
المسؤوله عن نصف انتاج ايطاليا من الزيت
مختصون طالبوا بقطع الاشجار المصابه
والتخلص من الاعشاب حول السليمه منها حيث
تضع الحشرات بيوضها كون هذه الطريقه هي
الافضل حاليا لمنع انتشار البكتيريا
القاتله